I think anyone who watches Numberphile's
really likely to be familiar with the
name John Conway. He's a really famous
mathematician, a really interesting
character and we've even featured him a
couple of times here on the channel.
- I'm not going to worry anymore,
ever again.
- But here's some
interesting news: there's
a new biography of Conway out, it's
called Genius at Play by Siobhan Roberts.
I'll tell you a bit more about the book
later, but first of all I want to show
you a video because Siobhan and some
people she's been working with, while
writing the book, made a short little
kind of film or mini documentary with
John Conway and they've decided to give
it its first viewing here on Numberphile.
So I'm going to play that film and then
I'll talk to you again afterwards.
[John Conway:] Yeah I don't actually
want to get rid of
my brain immediately, but I don't care,
you know,
after I'm dead I really don't-
I don't like thinking about that Memento
Mori; reminder of death.
- You're doing very well,
those pictures are looking great. We're
just going to do sort of calibration
type scans before we start the next part.
- You know, like all young people I was
immortal once. And like all people of
my present age I notice growing old. And
when I had a stroke five years ago I
really noticed; it was an abrupt
discontinuity in my life.
- So this is a
whole brain.
you could you could see that there are
two halves, two hemispheres - you can see
there's the left and the right
hemisphere. So the region that we're
particularly interested in in
John is the region somewhere over here.
It's the
parietal lobe; because as you know
different parts of the brain are very
involved in different functions, and of
course that's one of the things why we
think it's so fabulous that we're going
to be able to do functional magnetic
resonance imaging with you, because we
want to see which part of your brain is
particularly active when you're thinking
some of your great mathematical thoughts.
- I have this visual field problem.
I wasn't aware that I was being shown
two pictures for the first few seconds.
I only saw the left one.
- Okay, that's no problem we
might- might...
- Answering, sort of essentially stupid
questions, well not stupid but I mean is
this object here a rotation of this
object in some funny geometrical shape?
Well I couldn't care less whether it is
or not, you know, but I was trying to
answer the question I suppose. The thing
that made my name as mathematician
was the discovery of this amazing
geometrical group in 24 dimensions and
I distinctly remember at one time, sort
of, sitting in an armchair or
lying down on
the floor; I can't remember which
exactly it was,
and sort of waving my arms and legs in
the air because I needed to be able to
point in more directions than there are
in three-dimensional space, you know. And
that had more effect than the discovery
of the Surreal Numbers. Namely it affected
my career. I went from being an unknown
to being at the centre of the stage for
mathematicians, the world's stage in a
certain sense.
There's a magazine you
may have heard of called
Reader's Digest, and in one of these ones
it said 'Are you a tongue gymnast?'
I was a
student in Cambridge at the time and
then they gave four exercises. And it said
so far nobody has been found who can do
all four. And this sounded like a
challenge to me - let me do thick and
thin:
The clover leaf:
Almost unbelievable; the waves:
Rather than just staying at the age of
25, which I did for 25 years at least, I'm
aware now that there's only finitely
much to go; and it's a very very
different and rather frightening feeling.
You know- so this date, the 20th of
December, approached me, you know. At the
1st of December it was about three weeks
away, and it just inexorably approached
me and grew more and more frightening;
looming you know.
And now it's almost behind me.
If you'd like to see even more with John
Conway, of course we've got the videos
that we've made here on Numberphile. But,
to really get under his skin,
we're going to recommend this: Genius at
Play, Siobhan Roberts - there'll be links
under the video. I haven't read it all
yet, I've only just got it but I have
been going through it and I'm really
impressed. It's really interesting but
also really accessible and fun, I think
everyone from a mathematician through to
the layman like me will quite enjoy this
one. So have a look if you like and
thanks for watching today. Links below in
the video description - Genius at Play